[Music]
on this Sunday night terrorism concerns
and teens the rcmp's radicalization
warning for the parents of teenagers
after an Ottawa high schooler is charged
with Terror offenses it does certainly
appear that you know people are getting
younger and younger The Fallout from
Global's exclusive interview with the
teens
father as international calls for a
ceasefire grow louder what Israel is
showing the world it's uncovered
underground the prime minister's
popularity plummets but why a leadership
race could be a big risk for the
Liberals and she granted a thousand
wishes to terminally ill children there
was a lot I learned from the from the
children that I'm able actually to carry
forward forward now with my own
situation now it's her
turn global national with barin Asser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us we begin tonight with Fallout from a
story we broke last night here on global
news the arrest of a 15-year-old in
Ottawa accused of facilitating and
instructing terrorist activity against
Jewish people leaders from that
Community are urging Canadians to be
more Vigilant as the RCMP warns about a
unique rise in violent extremism among
teens the mount say there have now been
five Canadian teenagers arrested on
terror related cases since June
has our top story tonight the RCMP say
an Ottawa teens Targets in an alleged
terrorist attack Jewish people shocking
perhaps from a 15-year-old but with the
RCMP reporting a growing Trend in youth
being radicalized it's no longer
surprising the allegations against the
youth have not been proven meanwhile
Jewish communities across the country
are taking note and issuing warnings the
Jewish Federation of Ottawa released a
statement saying that while the police
assess there is is no risk because the
individual is in custody we ask that
everyone exercise heightened awareness
and diligence in following security
protocols it's a terrifying new reality
uh for Jewish communities around the
world including here in Canada um where
Jewish institutions synagogues schools
have been firebombed and shot at already
uh before this latest development in an
exclusive interview with global news the
Ottawa boy's father said his son was
naive and that the Iraqi family had
taken steps to prevent the youth from
being radicalized was more religious I
knew that and I warned many time he me
and his mother uh stay away from you
know extremist or something uh and we
his mom arranged some sessions with the
IM of the m to talk to him I think he
did and to keep them away from extremist
religious people you know we never had
this in in the family but Global News
later found Facebook post allegedly made
by the father according to the Facebook
translation of the Arabic posts they
refer to zionists and Jews in a
derogatory manner while one says to get
rid of all Israelis when asked if the
Facebook page was his the youth's father
said his lawyer had advised him not to
comment the posts were subsequently
deleted the center for Israel and Jewish
Affairs is now calling on the police to
investigate the father it's an
interesting it's sort of philosophical
theoretical question or debate when you
when you say well when are extremist
views extremist views when has somebody
become radicalized um what is a radical
view or a um a view that is just um
controversial like what are those lines
what are those dividing lines there
since June of this year the RCMP have
arrested five youth for alleged
terrorism including three teens in
Calgary who were arrested alongside a
20-year-old who admitted to posting an
Islamic State group recruitment video on
Tik Tok the RCMP are concerned enough
that Global News has learned they're
launching a national campaign to educate
parents about the signs of
radicalization mikro Lake Global News
Toronto Devastation and Desperation
continues in Gaza but there is some
relief as more Aid trucks are now being
allowed through another border crossing
but it's far from enough for the
hundreds of thousands of homeless and
hungry there in Rafa thousands of
Palestinians lined up on the streets all
to get some stew from emergency relief
workers the un's world food program has
warned about half of gaza's 2.3 million
people are starving as Israel continues
its Siege with thousands of Palestinians
already dead 70% women and children
according to the Hamas ran Health
Ministry it said today another 90 gazin
were killed by an Israeli strike at the
jabalia refugee camp in Northern Gaza
and the World Health Organization has
condemned the destruction of a hospital
in the region that's led to the deaths
of eight patients including a
99-year-old child Israel aims to keep up
its assault until Hamas is wiped out but
as Redmond Shannon reports International
pressure for a ceasefire is growing
stronger even from Israel's allies the
Subterranean tunnel in Northern Gaza
Israel's Defense Forces Show members of
the media what Israel says is the
biggest Hamas tunnel uncovered yet
without demolishing the tunnel project
of
Hamas we cannot demolish Hamas Parts
appear big enough to drive a vehicle
through and this is video released by
Israel which it says was filmed by Hamas
during Tunnel construction Israel says
the tunnel was used by Hamas militants
during the October 7th attacks which
triggered this
war on a visit to Israel and the
occupied West Bank France's foreign
minister called for an immediate
ceasefire her counterparts in Germany
and Britain wrote a joint newspaper
opinion piece Sunday saying they support
a ceasefire but only if it is
sustainable that may be somewhat
ambiguous but marks a shift in tone for
two Nations that abstained from
Tuesday's un ceasefire vote fighting is
not the answer right now we want our
people here many families of kidnapped
Israelis want a ceasefire
too Sunday's funeral hostage Alon shamr
a realization of their deepest fear he
and two other hostages mistakenly shot
dead by Israeli forces inside Gaza on
Friday prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
says Israel will fight until Hamas is
eliminated but he says negotiations with
Qatar and Egypt are ongoing to secure
the release of
hostages in Gaza the desperation of of
those stuck in a war zone illustrated by
the ever more frenzied scramble around
Aid trucks coming in from Egypt but in a
glimmer of good news Sunday Israel
allowed un Aid through the Kum Shalom
border crossing for the first time since
October 7th that should increase the aid
flow the Palestinian red Cresent says
before now only 10% of the aid need was
being fulfilled Redman Chann and Global
News
London in Ukraine one person has been
killed by debris from a downed Russian
drone Ukraine's Air Force says it
intercepted two missiles and 20 drones
from Russia overnight nine of them were
destroyed over Odessa including the one
that fell into a residential area and
killed a civilian three buildings were
also destroyed from the explosion of the
Fallen drone Ukraine says it's the third
Russian Air Assault on Odessa in the
past week at least 60 people are dead
off the coast of Libya after a boat
carrying migrants trying to reach Europe
cap sized the United Nations says it's
sunk due to strong waves in the
Mediterranean Sea overnight between
Thursday and Friday and according to
survivors there were 86 people on board
alarming new figures are out on how many
Canadians are dying due to the opioid
crisis in this country the national
numbers released on Friday showed nearly
4,000 Canadians lost their lives during
the first half of this year Ottawa says
no Community has been left untouched by
the toxic drug and overdose crisis as hi
traic reports it's a problem seeing a
surge in some Maritime communities
now it was at this encampment in
downtown Halifax where police and
paramedics responded to a medical
distress call Friday a man taken to
hospital and pronounced dead a volunteer
helping those living here devastated I
believe it was a drug overdose um and I
from what I've heard unconfirmed of
course that it was bad drugs it's a
growing issue 56 people people have died
this year in Nova Scotia due to
opioids not just a city problem though
last week the small community of Spring
Hill Nova Scotia held a public
information session so residents could
learn how to administer Nock Zone after
two men died in the town of suspected
overdoses Dr Mike gavic works with
vulnerable drug users in Halifax and
says tainted drugs are becoming more
common 5 years ago we hadn't seen fenel
or anything like this where in in the
west of Canada we it was all over um but
starting to emerge more and we're
starting to see the impacts of it you
know I've lost so many people close to
me G Mullins is a methodone user in
British Columbia where the coroner
service says the province has averaged
seven deaths a day for the past seven
weeks and is warning of toxic street
drugs there's cross-contamination so
even if you're doing cocaine or
something that fentanyl can sneak in
there the federal government says its
Canadian drugs and substances strategy
is working and that public health
interventions are making a difference
but Advocates would like to see much
more done we are not focusing on the
fact that this is a crisis of the drug
Supply that's why experts like cola have
written an open letter to WWA calling
for the expansion of safe Supply
programs across the country and longer
term funding for ones already operating
the issue is we've never scaled up these
interventions to address the scale and
the magnitude of the overdose crisis
across the country a crisis those on the
ground say is spreading and only made
words by lack of Housing and a
struggling healthare system Heidi petruk
Global News
Halifax an exclusive new Poll for global
news shows an overwhelming majority of
Canadians think it's time for prime
minister Justin Trudeau to step aside
more than two-thirds of Canadians think
he should resign in 2024 the Liberals
have been struggling in the polls but as
Abigail Bean tells us all signs point to
Trudeau staying the course and my
friends when the election comes the
Prime Minister has been consistent it
will be the honor of my life to lead us
through it he's not planning on going
anywhere Justin Trudeau has now become a
bit of a millstone for the Liberal Party
a new poll from IPO shows the vast
majority of Canadians 69% think he
should resign in 2024 and there's other
people who are kind of uh thinking that
you know any change is a good change and
then there's another group of people who
are saying in order to position the
party for the next election because I
can't vote for pulie Evan I can't vote
for Singh I need another option on the
liberal bench despite many wanting him
to leave 63% don't think he will Prime
Ministers don't usually leave on their
own uh most of them either go down to
defeat or or in or get pushed out by
their own party but there's no ER
apparent uh in the liberal party that is
mobilizing to push him out like there
was with the Martin cretan folks and
that means a leadership race between now
and the next election would present a
risk for the liberals who have built so
much around the Trudeau brand even if
that brand has lost some of its shine
during the government's eight-year run a
leadership race at this point would
divide the party would expose divisions
that are already there would create
question marks around what the party
stands for even more than there is now
there are now and I think the
conservatives would do what they do
really well which is jump out and Define
the person right away before they get a
chance to do it themselves if Trudeau
stays on a different danger with these
numbers are the people who choose to sit
out the next election they may not want
Trudeau to be prime minister again but
they're not prepared to vote
conservative or NDP and experts say that
can cause not just low voter turnout but
volatility in the electoral system and
for funding critical for the campaign
Abigail Bean Global News
Ottawa anet zero facelift the European
inspired retrofit plan that's made its
way to Alberta plus giving and receiving
a woman who changed the lives of
hundreds of terminally ill children now
is asking for some help of her
own as the climate crisis pushes people
to look for greener Solutions there's an
effort to transform older homes into
modern energy efficient dwellings as
Jasmine King explains in some cases
homes more than 50 years old are only
steps away from becoming Net Zero the
hoopen family is all about living green
they have solar panels and now are
taking it to the next level just with
the modern Technologies we have now it's
like this is the time to to do this the
Hoffman decided to deep retrofit their
home meaning giving it a face lift
replacing the original exterior of the
house with new panels to keep heat in
the cold out and reduce energy use
instantly the day they put the
insulation in the panel on the house it
was quieter and within an hour the whole
house was almost the same temperature
there's no more cold spots hotspots the
Hoffman were one of three families that
took part in the retrofit Canada pilot
project the idea was sparked from a
method used in Europe and made its way
to Alberta Edmonton's always been a hot
spot for Net Zero housing it's uh it's a
really great place to see how this
business is growing with some of the
first NetZero homes in Canada um built
here what makes this unique the three
homes are all more than 50 years old the
changes took months the retrofit isn't
cheap but money will be saved in the
long run the three homes drastically
cutting their energy use and their bills
depends on your overall energy usage but
you can easily cut uh 50% of your energy
bill by uh doing a deep retrofit and
once you add solar then you can
basically cut all of the energy bill
heat pumps and air filters are also a
big part of the changes we know that
when we have Smoky days um we can filter
our air we're not having a bunch of air
exchange through the Leaky envelope of a
regular house but that air is coming in
through a place where we can filter it
um and so it's also yeah just having
that peace of mind for the Hoffmans it's
one step closer to their goal of Net
Zero setting an example in our local
community just like this is possible
Jasmine King Global News it's
ahead the plan to tackle a growing
grizzly bear problem in pton
[Music]
BC residents in a BC Community are
asking for the government's help to
coexist with grizzly bears encounters
are growing as the Bears population
thrives in the pton area which is just
North of Whistler and as Paul Johnson
reports it's a complicated issue with no
easy solution
in the Farm and Ranch Country Northwest
of pton the return of the grizzly is
either terrifying or thrilling depending
on who you talk to what we're hearing
from Farmers and residents of the pon
Valley is that there are more bare
sightings than we've ever really
experienced in recent memory Grizzlies
were shot out of this Valley long ago
but changing views and the ending of the
trophy hunt in BC have allowed their
numbers to grow again with curious and
hungry bears now wandering where they
haven't been in decades Jen Ford is the
chair of the Squamish louette Regional
District we're hearing that some
Grizzlies are uh boldly accessing
Farmland um they're traveling into areas
that they traditionally have not
traveled before and there's a lot of
concern among the things they're
learning in pton is the challenge of
relocating grizzly bears earlier this
fall they moved one over to the Stein
Valley which is a long way and over the
mountains it was back in a few days the
situation has prompted the regional
district to reach out to the province
for guidance on a Grizzly coexistence
strategy they'd like to get some plans
drawn up before the Bears emerge from
hibernation in the spring education
Public Safety and management of
attractants will all likely be on the
table we have to up our game because
we're building communities more and more
into bare habitat so interactions are
going up for sure coming into the city
or into the town of pton I'll say um is
a safety hazard for there's a lot of
families and a lot of um you know
pedestrians that live here well
Grizzlies are on the move so is public
perception particularly in a place
that's seen an influx of new residents
whose reason to come here was to
experience wild BC I mean I think they
should be left alone obviously or or or
even if that's possible move them
further out there but I wouldn't want to
see any harm come to them basically
because they lived here long before we
did as the SE to Sky Region comes up
with a new Grizzly plan it's worth
noting that for all the sightings and
concern we couldn't find a single report
of an aggressive move by a Grizzly here
this year let alone a case where anyone
was hurt in pton Paul Johnson Global
News
[Music]
next a terminally ill woman who made
kids wishes come true for decades now
has one of her
[Music]
own around 40 years ago Michelle
Harrison established a charity aimed in
making dreams come true for kids who
were battling life-threatening illnesses
well now the Winnipeg Woman Behind The
Dream Factory is planning one last act
of giving back back as she faces a
similar struggle of her own Katherine
Dorian reports in 1983 Michelle Harrison
helped arrange for a young boy with
brain cancer to meet his Idol Wayne
Gretzky this was the beginning of
something big the Dream Factory a
nonprofit that gives kids facing
life-threatening illnesses Unforgettable
experiences Michelle never thought she'd
be on the receiving end of a Dream
Factory experience but sadly she's now
facing her own battle I feel like I'm
going to um uh pass away with some sense
of I look I did something uh for for the
kids that I uh worked with for uh for
many years and leaving this Legacy
behind with the Dream Factory of 40
years um just seemed the the best thing
to do now battling terminal lung cancer
Michelle wants to spend her remaining
time giving back the Dream Factory is
aiming to raise $60,000 for her living
Memorial campaign executive director
Andrew cus says that money will go
towards creating more dreams for kids
we're trying to do as much as we can so
that we can continue to be an
organization that says yes to each and
every child and family that we meet um
and never have to put a limit on on what
a dream can be or how many kids and
families were able to help the dreams
might be a trip to Disneyland or smaller
things like a pet or a makeover for
their bedroom Andrew says demand has
skyrocketed with over 70 referrals for
kids this year up from 28 last year
Michelle says giving kids something to
look forward to and hope for is very
important it was um incredibly rewarding
especially you know talking to the
children and hearing how their their
wish panned out and how happy they were
and the family you know as it is a
really the family going through the
whole thing with the child with over a
thousand wishes granted in the past 40
years she wants them to Grant a thousand
more especially since working with the
kids has made her own mortality easier
to face I learned about Grace I learned
about not to be
afraid um there was a lot I learned from
the from the children that I'm able
actually to carry forward forward now
with my own situation wanting to carry
that hope forward for those she'll leave
behind Katherine Doran Global
News and that is global national for
this Sunday night I'm faran AER on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your Sunday evening with us tonight's
your cada is the Toys R Us in South
Edmonton which is teamed up with the
Starlight Foundation to give a group of
critically sick children a private
shopping spree Toys R West Canada's
raised $28 million for Star like Canada
since the organizations teamed up 24
years ago Donna will be back with you
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night
[Music]